on this episode I give a Jets Colts
prediction we talk sandwiches and when
was I wrong
last
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 141 of
the ask gary vee show super pumped this
is a Friday it's really Thursday as you
can tell I tape the night before that's
what was Thursday's episode and I'm
leaving for a wedding on Friday but
Friday's episode which is the official
Jets prediction show so I'm excited to
give you my two cents on that I'll save
that for the end of the show I'm gonna
be like a TV show where you save the
good stuff for the end to make them
watch all the way through for the
ratings I'm in a good mood and stud1
let's get into the show
expected me to do something new see I
got that was good right I killed them I
got you on that one
cuz you were trying to figure out when
my kids was I went in for it you're a
bad person
bad bad I'm a bad I'm a bad man David
asks what would you do if you were the
new CEO of Twitter how would you turn
that ship around David I do a couple
things one I would recognize that the
data that we're collecting on a daily
basis is disproportionately valuable to
a lot of real-time marketers and
real-time data analysts you saw a
Bloomberg Twitter JV come across the
headlines for me I haven't read it yet
but that's exactly where I'd go putting
my money where my mouth is I invested in
a company called Data Miner years ago
that I felt Twitter [ __ ] would or should
buy or become a big company on the
backbone of that I would also recognize
that normal people don't understand
Twitter Twitter as a product is not as
easy to understand as Facebook and
Instagram and that is a friction point
when you look at the data that shows how
many people have signed up for Twitter
but then have not been active that's a
vulnerability so I would hire the single
best product guy that I could or gal and
so a product person would be very very
very high my list I would not guess I
would poach with all my ability with
disproportional economics and give them
as much stock as I had to from a
facebook or and
things of that nature I would probably
make a very aggressive plan
I would change the logo of the bird I
would probably change it to a cat and
have the cat eat the bird as a symbolic
notion - it's a totally different
company so I think you'd need a branding
play that would change the optics so
change the logo from bird to a cat
I would tell Wall Street that they
should start selling my stock now
because I'm not going to be a CEO that's
gonna confine itself to making numbers
on an every 90 day basis and that I have
empathy for that's how they have their
business and I probably only would have
gotten a job as CEO of Twitter if I
communicated that to the board and the
biggest stockholders who then clearly
weirdly allowed me to go become the CEO
because they wouldn't care about their
stock price over a 24 month period
because it would go way way down because
my behaviors more predicated on bidding
business building not so much Wall
Street appeasing so there's a lot of
things that I would do I would also
recognize that Twitter is one of the
true social networks that the value in
listening is very big on Twitter
whereas Instagram Pinterest Facebook you
know tumblr they are snapchat it's
pushing content out it's more of a
content management system CMS where
Twitter has a lot of listening
capabilities it is where you have a
conversation it is the place you go for
now when something happens in the world
cuz people want to talk you know
starting to move a little bit in
surrender some of that behavior but
those are some of the top-line things I
would do Camile asks how would you raise
money for a college Business Club we'd
love to bring more members to a New York
City competition camille i think raising
money is all about asking i would uh let
me pretend Steve and I would we're
partners Steve we need to raise more
money okay who do you know is do you
have a rich uncle yeah actually I put
the weird let's call him and so that's
been fun II know that was that was
basically what we would do you'd have to
what I think you need to do is you need
to map the 1,000 people that you can ask
all the way from and you notice I went
uncle - hey that kid in our school looks
like he dresses
extremely well he might have some money
like I'm not kidding like you raising
monies is called asking for money so you
have to get into the behavior of asking
for money so you map on piece of paper
or hammer in you know collect the data
who are you gonna ask for money you
start with your mother and the people
that you're closest to or for me one of
the biggest things I do in business is I
start with you know I can think of three
or four executives right now that I
could ask anything for cuz I brought
them so much value remember why I like
job so much when you really need it it's
nice to be like hey Rick
I need a million bucks and when Rick
knows that I've disproportionally put
eight million in his pocket he still
makes a no and remember if you ever read
the article I'm still ok with that but
it's nice to know that Rick would be at
the top of the list along with uncle
Milford ranch uncle Billy you know what
a rich uncle you know what I want it no
Andrew Andrew get in here next question
I do question from some of my thinking
hey media employee
Oh God get in here Andrew the
vaynernation is very excited about this
moment don't worry I'm not checked I'm
not testing your Jets fandom I need you
to make a new shirt for our collection I
want it for next week's episode a rich
uncle Milford we recreated a fake
character here his name is rich uncle
Milford it's got a rich uncle
don't give him creative rich uncle
Milford and then just and you're good at
drawing draw rich uncle Milford lots of
bucks
sweet little chat all right get out here
make make him look like an old version
of stunwin all right you're gonna wear
it thank you very the sandwich
enthusiast here Sam talked a lot about
how video is the future of social media
how do you decide which video content
goes on which video platform and
secondly the New York Jets were sandwich
what type of sandwich would they be ah
keep answering questions I'll keep
making sandwiches so man Travis oh he
always get caught with that
a wonderful vaynermedia employee here
Shawn
you know I reverse engineer audiences so
Facebook's incredible and I have a
complete hard-on for Facebook because if
I want to make a video for a sixty to
eighty year old female I know what kind
of content goes there versus a 30 to 35
year-old male who's a Jets fan who lives
in New Jersey I can curse there I can be
Jersey right like if I'm doing a video
for 52 to 58 year old females who are
fans of Joel Osteen and live in South
Carolina it might not be the right video
to be like you let the said that might
not work right so so one I love Facebook
for that because I feel like gives me
the whole breath Instagram skews 40 and
under snapchat I get real silly I can be
really ridiculous though rainbows you
know and so so it's about reverse
engineering the audience who's gonna
consume it where is it gonna be
Twitter because I think it's more news
oriented more things to that nature so
maybe a video where I'm talking about
breaking news or my thought like my
thoughts on snapchat or the other day
that would been a video I would have
definitely debated to go into Twitter
because so many people in news world are
hardcore on Twitter so if they saw that
they retweeted I get distribution so
it's reverse engineering reverse
engineering Shawn if the Jets were
sandwich they'd be a sloppy joe Thank
You Kyle asks when was the last time you
were wrong and how did you handle it
Kyle this is a great question damn it
someone I'm wrong a lot I don't talk
about being wrong a lot because here's
the secret weapon guys we it's taken a
hundred and forty-one episodes to get to
the secret weapon
stunwin the secret weapon to why I am
the way I am Stefan I need massive
graphics right now give me some like
Rockets coming up here secret weapon
I am wrong so much it's kind of scary
but for some unknown reason I haven't
fully quantified this I'm not capable of
giving it much thought and actually
spend zero time post gaming it
I don't micro analyze for hours days
weeks months years and this is for some
of you out there lives for your whole
life your micro analyzing why you made
that mistake you know use a good mistake
I passed on uber 'he's angel round and
left two hundred million dollars cold
hard cash out of my pocket in a world
where my game is being a businessman i
would argue that my biggest mistake is
disproportionately bigger than any of my
victories I just don't you know I'm just
not crippled by have friends who passed
on things and they just can't ever get
over it get over it so what was my last
mistake I probably made one in my last
meeting I'm probably making one right
now you know like I make tons of wrong
hires I I I say things that don't sell
in a meeting I make bad investments I I
make wrong strategies I started for
massive initiatives for vaynermedia this
year to crush to or failing like I mean
I you know I make mistakes all day I
just don't respect my mistakes best wine
club asks how do you define value wine
and what are a couple of your favorites
the way I define value wine is by
tasting I have a great palate and deeply
knowledgeable wine palate at this point
I like to say most so myself but this
answers for anybody who's into wine when
I taste something that I know taste a
hell of a lot better than what I paid
for it it's obvious to me it's very
obvious the chocolate box that we're
selling today on Wine Library a big push
actually here comes right hook put the
big label here and link it up
Stefan and Facebook and YouTube guys you
should buy this wine it's $13 and 88
cents it tastes like it's a $35 wine the
end that's value so to me when I you
know it's like that Senator who said
when they were defining pornography on
the Internet
on Capitol Hill and he was like I don't
know how to define it but when I see it
I know what pornography is I can't fully
define it for you but the second I taste
it because I've contacts that scale I
know what it is and so to me the thing
that you should be thinking about is um
tasting wines if you like them and you
feel good about what you paid for it
I'll give you a couple fun facts so I
gave you the chocolate box I would say
Portugal's a great region to try a lot
of value for Shores the Italian Reds
there's a ton of value in non Chianti's
tusky non Tuscany non piedmont there's a
lot of stuff but just try a lot of wines
in the 8 to 15 dollar range
it's an incredible sweet spot there's a
ton of wine and some why don't we take
this answering this question and write
an article on garyvaynerchuk.com
of my 8 let's do this my 11 favorite
wines at eleven dollars in under and
then we'll link it to this and we'll
catch up with it so that was actually
fun a little more wine once in a while
said official prediction time guys I
predicted the Jets would to be two ten
and six in last episode I had the Colts
as one of the Jets losses but I'm
affected by last week we got to see
everybody play in real time and I think
the Indianapolis Colts are broken in the
trenches on the offense and defensive
line which is like the core of you know
Mike the trainer taught me my core was
very important that to me is a core of a
football team the trenches I think
they're broken and I think the Jets ride
the momentum of last week's win since
second half and stun the annapolis Colts
on Monday Night Football which I will be
there I'm gonna make a sign Marshall and
then the end is gonna be a D and
Fitzpatrick so I'm gonna try to get on
TV look for me and as we reflect do you
reckon somebody make that sign from a
chemical science anyway but real quick
the official score of the game is I
think the Jets score I can just score in
this game I'm going 26 21 New York Jets
it's not over D Rock I'm doing the whole
you know statement of the day and then I
got you know I don't know if you missed
the cadence of how we do it here
statement of the day what is your
lack of the week I like the football
stuff and I'm pleased again feedback on
today's show what do you think about the
questions the answers give me some
feedback and the wine stuff is that fun
- in dejection we go in other directions
trying to get a little more detail than
some stuff as well you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them